foreign
[Music]
coming up on FYI our exams getting too
hard it's so unfair that you have one
day to prove how smart you are
I'm going to be learning some life and
outdoor skills from the most famous bear
of all time Bear Grylls
[Music]
hello this is your Weekly News show FYI
where you get to report on your own
story so for a lot of us exam season is
truly underway it can be quite a
stressful time have you guys been doing
your exams well my exams start after the
half term but I've definitely been
getting nervous about them yeah I've had
a couple this week and they've been
pretty tiring to be honest
so there's gcses and a levels Scotland
National fives and hires and just
recently year six pupils in England took
the standard assessment tests known as
SATs
so that's a test made up of maths and
English to measure our progress in
school some parents and teachers have
complained about the recent English
science test saying it was too long and
the questions were too tough so lots of
pupils couldn't finish it some people
are asking if we actually need these
tests at all so what have the government
said or a spokesperson from the
Department of Education said that the
SATs were rigorously trialled and
reviewed by experts to make sure that
they are appropriate for all pupils but
they said they will continue to work
with schools children and parents to
understand the views of this year's
papers well it's time to get your shout
on this we went to an FYI News Club at
Saint ansan's Catholic Primary School in
Dartford to hear what they think about
exams
when I came into the test I started to
freak out so much and always looking at
the time back up my test my time the
test the I just felt angry and think it
was unfair I think there are other ways
to do it maybe not have a timer because
I've always been against that it puts
you under pressure when the time is up
and you still haven't finished your
paper or I'm just asking that we know
the difficulty level because it can
really help us to manage physically and
mentally what we're going to do we could
have another way to test because not
many people have their strong point in
Russian English to take science you
could take other subjects I personally
think that are not necessary because
when we go to secondary school we all
have to do tests anyways to see what
position you're put in and what you need
to focus on I actually found it very
difficult I was scared when I was doing
it because I I didn't know if I was
going to get the answers right at some
point we are all 11 if you're not
getting that same range of difficulty it
is not fair they are
like putting us to higher standards than
the last year so I am just frustrated
and angry at them not many people might
like it but they should probably redo it
and make another status I hope sats are
easier for other people because I also
know a few other people that are younger
than me and they're going to do this
that soon I don't want them to stress I
want them to be calm yeah
are you guys any good at spotting fake
news I think we're pretty good yeah I
mean I can be good but it always seems
to surprise me well check out this video
that I found online apparently it's a
video of a sofa flying through the sky
during a storm in turkey that can't be
real
so what do you think is it fake news or
is it fact well we'll find out later
[Music]
so do you guys reckon you've got the
skills to survive in the woods or a
desert island I'd survive on a tropical
island if that's what you mean yeah with
like sun beds and a water park and loads
of fruit like mangoes and coconuts and
pineapples well I wasn't too sure until
I chatted to Adventure or Bear Grylls
he's taking on some of the toughest
challenges in some of the harshest
environments in the world and now he's
written a book for young people about
never giving up I headed to the woods to
find out more
hi there how are you hey Joe I'm nice to
meet you nice so good yeah what are we
doing today well we're gonna make a
little fire fire can save your life if
you've got a camp overnight and you need
warmth you need protection yeah if you
lit a fire before no well we're gonna
make it really hard today no match no no
lighter no all you've got is a fire
Striker and all this is gonna do is
create a few Sparks look just like this
and with that
you can light a huge fire sometimes all
we need is a little spark a little kind
of a little something that gives us a
leg up in life and then from that little
fire
like with you you're going to go on to
do so many amazing things should we get
the far going first and then we can then
we can relax and we can stay warm yeah
this is so cool so what's the best way
to do this safely make sure you're with
someone who knows what they're doing
like you obviously you've got to be
super careful of uh of forest fires yeah
make sure you've got water nearby or
fire extinguisher or something make sure
you're making it not in dry grass areas
okay so Gerard you're gonna do this yes
okay to get you to aim the spark
into there just like this okay
oh
there you go there you go you got it you
got it you got it yeah
there you go here it goes it's on it's
gone
look at that yes and then you can ask
any questions you like your eye so you
shared your stories and Adventures in
your books and on TV your latest book is
far beyond that it teaches us life
lessons what inspired you to write that
it's designed for people like you
setting out in life because there's you
know life is tough school is tough and
like all all good Adventures you want to
be prepared so it's all the things I've
learned to my life that have helped me
get ahead one's a time you had to free
some images setback or failure on what
did that teach you
well I've had so many failures in my
life and people don't always realize
that because you see the successes don't
you when I first tried to join the
military and tried to join the SAS and I
failed that first time and that was
gutting for me you know and but I
remember going back and I got a second
time ramp so whatever you want to do in
life you're going to get some setbacks
just take it as a good sign it means
you're doing something right you're on
the right path yeah just keep going
so you've been to some of the world's
[Music]
ultimate I mean do you think we should
continue to tackle it or do you think we
should just learn to live and adapt to
it
well one thing I think we should never
do is give up yeah and you know the the
reality of climate change is that it's
it's real and it's having a devastating
effect on wildlife and on people
especially vulnerable populations around
the world where sea level rises have
devastating effects and you see it I see
it all the time when we're away on
adventures I see it in the extreme
weather patterns and you know a lot of
flooding and a lot of droughts so we can
all do something about it and even from
the smallest things of recycling your
rubbish so get smart and do what you can
to protect something you love so you
have kids right yeah three boys if there
was one piece of advice any advice you
could give them what would it be I think
you've got to follow your dreams in life
yeah you know be resilient be the most
dogged determined resilient never give
up person you know follow this
never give up thank you so so much and
our Fire's been doing really well the
whole time we've been talking we've
warmed up yeah it was raining yeah it
was Anna and this is nice
check this out the first ever full-sized
digital scans of the famous shipwreck
the Titanic have been released
the Titanic sank in 1912 after hitting
an iceberg in the Atlantic Ocean and
more than 1500 people lost their lives
its story has always fascinated people
and it was even made into a Hollywood
movie
these new 3D scans were made using
remote controlled robots that took more
than 700 000 images the letter c the
entire ship as if the water has been
drained away
thank you fancy going to the Moon well
another billionaire has just joined the
Space Race to try and make that possible
the U.S base agency Nassau has been
working with billionaire Elon Musk to
land two astronauts on the moon over the
next few years
but now Amazon founder Jeff Bezos has
also signed a contract with Nassau to
build a different landing craft that
will hopefully take a whole crew to the
surface of the Moon by the end of this
decade
so why are we so desperate to explore
space well if you just don't get it
don't worry because Scarlet's been
investigating
[Music]
welcome to my virtual world or to be
more accurate my virtual Moon
in July 1969 the world watched him
Wonder as Neil Armstrong became the
first man to walk on the moon
[Music]
it was an incredible achievement with
some pretty basic technology
he was the first out of just 12 humans
to have ever walked on the moon All
American astronauts and all men
nobody's been back since 1972 but
finally American space agency NASA is
preparing to return
three two one booster's indignation
and liftoff of Artemis one we rise
together back to the moon and Beyond
the brilliant thing about the Moon is
that its gravity is only one-sixth of
what it is on Earth so you can take
giant leaps
easily breaking World high jump records
plus it comes with an awesome view back
to Planet Air
but I couldn't possibly survive for real
dressed like this as there's no
atmosphere on the moon so astronauts
need their own very special spacesuits
with their own supply of air
NASA's Artemis project is aiming to take
a diverse crew to the Moon including the
first woman eventually they hope to have
a permanent base on the surface of the
Moon where astronauts can stay for
months at a time
it'll cost a fortune though so why do it
while his space scientist Dr Maggie
aderon pocock to help us answer that
question
part of it is the spirit of Adventure
part to learn new things like how to
live away from Earth or the challenge
for instance of Designing a base on the
moon NASA has said it also wants to send
astronauts to one of Earth's closest
neighbors Mars by the 2030s at its
nearest it's around 34 million miles
away and it'll take at least seven
months to get there
[Music]
Maggie the moon base could be a help
here couldn't it yes that's right if
you've ever seen a rocket launch you can
see that taking off from the surface of
the Earth requires a huge amount of fuel
also sending people to Mars means a lot
of supplies for the journey there and by
but as you mentioned the moon has just
one-sixth of the Earth's gravity so
launching from a moon base would require
a lot less fuel
and with water now been detected on the
moon it may be possible to make the fuel
up there on the moon's surface we've got
a good idea of what the surface of Mars
is like so let's check it out
pretty cool right you might not know
this but we've already managed to land
lots of probes and several Rovers to
explore the dusty surface
they've sent back amazing pictures
so what would it be like living here on
Mars
the biggest challenge is the atmosphere
it's mainly carbon dioxide which means
we can't breathe it so that means
wearing a spaceseed whenever we're
outside
then there's the temperature
Mars is further away from the Sun than
the Earth is so it's colder on average
the Martian surface gets a little warmer
but a lot colder than Antarctica
before and there's no quick rescue if
things go wrong is there
from the Martian surface the Earth just
looks like a bright star in the sky
call for help message will take between
5 and 20 minutes to get to the Earth
depending on the relative position of
the two planets
and even if a rescue mission was
launched straight away it would take
around six months for it to get to Mars
so will we ever be able to go on holiday
to another planet well there aren't
going to be hotels popping up on mars or
even the moon anytime soon but companies
like Virgin Galactic and SpaceX and now
taking people into space at a price
in science fiction films humans live all
over the universe so could that ever
become a reality
I'd really love to think that this may
be possible in the future
in our galaxy The Milky Way There are
around 300 billion stars and we're now
finding planets going around many of
these stars as humans it's hard to
imagine a more perfect place to live
than Earth but the space age is very
young so imagine where we might be in 50
or even a hundred years time wow thanks
so maybe just maybe science fiction
could eventually become facts beam me up
[Music]
nice and Scarlet so did you think the
video of the flying sofa was fake news
well it's actually a fact the sofa was
seen flying through the air before
crashing into a building during storm
force winds in Turkey's capital city
Ankara
foreign
well that's it for this week but don't
forget if you have a story and want to
report for FYI why not set up an FYI
News Club at your school all the info
can be found on our website at first dot
news forward slash FYI see you next time
bye